hello everyone and welcome to a video
that is completely different than all of
my other videos why is it completely
different you ask well it's because this
video uses an infinite chess board and
to really show you what I mean by an
infinite chess board first we're gonna
use this chess board to show to show
just you know a very simple puzzle so
here in this puzzle it's black to move
its like to move but the real question
is in how many moves does white win so
as you can see it's not a very
complicated position black black King is
pretty much stuck here and if he's not
very careful white will simply play
Queen here and this will be checkmate
moving the rock for example here will
result in Queen here checkmate
so black pretty much has very few
options if he goes something like rock
here then you get rocky for check King
moves and Queen Queen to see for this
will be checkmate so this is checkmate
in two moves this is in in the event
that black actually plays a roof to d6
if black plays rook to d7 then white
checkmate in three moves so here it is
check King moves check again King moves
and rookie six this will be checkmate
another thing black can play instead of
rook to d6 or rook to d7 black can go
rook to d8 if black plays rook to b8
then you get rocky 4 check King moves
Quincy four check King moves brookey six
check King moves and Quinta c6 and this
will be checkmate so it's not a very
complicated puzzle but it's not a very
complicated puzzle on a on a finite
board what if we make the board infinite
so as I don't really have the option of
making the board infinite I can add a
couple of layers here so here we can add
a layer down there and a layer up there
so they're not the board is infinite it
goes all the way up and all the way down
so now the d8 is not the final square
there's also d9b 10 the 11 to 12 D 13
and I will put a link in the description
below where you can watch a very nice
video by the PBS infinite series youtube
channel they really made a nice video
where they use this puzzle although they
used it without without to this King so
I added this to make it a really a chess
puzzle and they they're mostly
interested in it you know for
mathematical purposes but I it seemed
very interesting to me a subscriber
Jevon Kearse send it to me over twitter
so I watched their video and it was very
nice I do recommend it for all of you to
watch it but it's very interesting
because they say now that if black
decides to move this rook for example an
infinite number of squares up in how
many moves does white win so intro video
like I said do check it out it's really
interesting white will eventually win
because black can like move this rook
all the way up like okay I can't go to
d9 because my interface doesn't allow me
but if it could it could go maybe to D D
7 millions or something white would
still have a win but it will just take
him a whole whole other moves so that's
actually not true because they're only
interested in this for some mathematical
purposes if black went for example to D
60 was that it would actually be a draw
due to the 50 move rule because no piece
would be captured and no pawn would be
moved so after 50 moves of simply moving
Queen and rook trying to capture King it
would it would simply not work so how do
we how do you do this it's a it's very
interesting I mean that's that's what
got me interested so what what I was
thinking is could there maybe be could
there maybe be a position where if you
use an infinite board of course where
white would be winning on a finite board
but if we used an infinite board that it
wasn't it will not be a draw like in
this case but it would actually favor
black so that's something something that
I started thinking about and I really
couldn't couldn't find any positions
like that but maybe you know there are a
lot of you maybe I mean maybe you can
find such a position and that would that
would really be interesting so a losing
position but if you make the board in
then it's like the other guys winning so
that would be very interesting so yeah
basically that's that's just what I
wanted to show you as this is the first
time I actually heard of infinite chess
thought it was quite a quite an
interesting concept so I mean I I do
hope you enjoyed it and I would like to
thank Beal all I want for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it and I really do suggest
you watch the video in the description
it's not very long really it's like 12
minutes maybe 19 I'm not sure either 12
or 19 so do check it out and it really
talks a lot about infinite chests and
about infinity in general in other games
so if you enjoy things like that maybe
maybe a little little bit of math do
check it out
so yeah as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I do hope you enjoyed this
video as it is a bit different than all
of my other videos but you know it's
always good to mix things up a little
bit so thank you all and I will see you
soon